The average American will move 11.3 times
over the course of their life.
There are many different reasons: finding
a better home, finding a cheaper home, getting
a new job, getting married, going to college,
getting evicted…
Whether it’s a happy reason or a bummer,
I don’t know anyone who actually enjoys
the process of moving.
The planning, the packing, the cleaning, the
expense.
But we’ve got your back!
No, we can’t actually help you load the
truck.
Sorry.
But we do have 9 hacks to save money on your
move.
You may have to break your back, but you can
avoid breaking the bank.
Look around your house.
How many individual “things” do you think
are in it?
If it’s the average American household,
that number is 300,000.
The idea of transporting 300,000 items from
one location to another is… daunting.
And the more you have to move, the more expensive
it will be.
So let’s get that number down, shall we?
When you’re a month or two out, make a list
of all the rooms in your house and focus on
one per week.
Your job is to pick up every item in that
room and ask yourself if you really still
like it.
This is not the time to be precious!
Aunt Helga will never find out you got rid
of her lamp.
You can sell the unwanted items online, or
just donate them to a local charity.
As long as it’s not broken or filthy, Goodwill
will take just about anything!
For a lot of different reasons, summer is
the most popular time to move.
More than 30 million Americans move at this
time of year, and another 30 million are traveling
for vacation, which means the highways are
packed, and so are movers’ schedules.
If you can wait until the fall or early winter,
it can save you money.
Movers are less busy so they will sometimes
lower their rates by up to 30%.
And less traffic on the roads means more efficient
travel times.
And if you’re loading the truck yourself,
wouldn’t you rather do it when it’s not
100 degrees?
If you’re a renter, there are a variety
of reasons that a landlord can refuse to give
your security deposit back, so reread your
lease terms to make sure you’re in compliance.
Getting a check for a couple thousand can
be a huge help in offsetting your moving costs.
You can hire movers to do EVERYTHING--pack,
load, drive, unload, unpack--but it gets expensive!
An inter-city move of a two bedroom apartment
would cost us about two grand here in Austin.
Maybe that’s why only 21% of people use
professionals from start to finish.
Instead, if you pack your own things, rent
your own van and drive it yourself, suddenly
you’re only paying $500 for the load-in
and load-out, which, let’s be honest, is
no one’s favorite part of the job.
1 out of 10 moves are for work, and if that
includes you, you should definitely inquire
about a relo package as part of your contract.
39% of all moving shipments are actually paid
for by corporations.
And unlike salary, it’s a one-time expense
that often comes from a different part of
the company’s budget, so they might be more
open to it than you think.
Remember, if you don’t ask, the answer is
always NO.
Why spend money on packing material when you
have already have closets of soft stuff at
hand?
Wrap your dishes and other breakables in clothes,
towels and linens to protect them and cut
down on waste.
Sure, it’s a little heavier than styrofoam
or bubble wrap, but you’re bringing this
stuff along anway!
As my Uncle Olav used to say, “Only a sucker
pays for cardboard boxes.”
Okay, I don’t have an Uncle Olav, but seriously,
there are SO many places to get them for free:
Craigslist, Facebook, NextDoor, Freecycle,
or drop by your local grocery or liquor stores--they
may be happy to let you take them off their
hands.
And, yes, I have personally pulled boxes out
of recycling dumpsters behind a hardware store.
It’s actually pretty common for people to
leave the fridge and pantry till the last
minute, and then decide they’d rather throw
everything away than worry about perishables
going bad in a hot moving truck.
This is such a waste of food, especially considering
it can cost hundreds to restock a pantry from
scratch in your new home.
So in the weeks before your move, commit to
consuming as much as you can from what you
already have.
The things you can’t eat will probably fit
into one or two plastic tubs you can transport
yourself.
Honestly, a bottle of olive oil can cost 10
bucks.
That baby is coming with me!
This is probably the most important money-saving
tip we can give you.
Wanna sell your furniture instead of giving
it away?
That takes time.
Wanna find free boxes instead of buying them?
Wanna properly clean your apartment so you
can get your security deposit back?
That takes time.
Moving always takes longer than you think,
and the more rushed you are, the more it’ll
cost you.
So kick off your moving plan at least two
months in advance of your last day in your
old home.
It will also make the experience safer and
more pleasant.
Oh, and chiropractors are expensive, so lift
with your legs, not with your back.
And that’s our two cents!